Oh
Hausa comb run my name hey back welcome
back to the most gorgeous couple in the
entire universe
this time rose this time I will finish
this game I swear on my nipples right
nipple I will do something really
terrible to it
if we don't finish it tonight it's going
down and it's going down to Funkytown
just gotta remember not to say Matt yeah
that's just that's all we got a joke
whoa whoa hang on it what are you doing
great grace what are you doing in there
what da [ __ ] is going on
of course I'm writing time I'm a
Gonzales whoa telepods in my face hallo
what the hell is this sorcery tell me
what's going on here no no here you are
you were here right one second ago
what are you doing go through the what
are you what is this [ __ ] don't come
closer don't come close I have your
phone it's been a long time you freaky
practice
all right the way you look wonderful my
thank you I haven't shaved my nipple
nipples
but that won't come closer yeah I know
that's about damn money and make
yourself at home
but I am sort of calming alright already
don't come close to me door oh god damn
it I am seeing you again makes me
remember the wonderful times will you
yes I know we used to have get laid but
don't tell trip here comes all right we
weren't talking about anything delay
right it was pretty sweet oh I just
realized that I think that you have a
small dick Oh tonight's a special night
okay that a celebration in fact what do
you mean
Gonzalo remember it was almost exactly
10 years ago tonight that you introduced
us I remember I introduced you because
you were I thought really want to thank
you for
here I thought you both were pretty
obnoxious I how'd you go pretty well
together
hey exactly agony pain and suffering in
the vajayjay that's what I talk about
all the time no no it's uh it's great
you could be here tonight yeah so thank
you you two really are getting along
well tonight maybe it's because we are
the same size of penis I mean no no no
no we have the odd photo I just pulled
up from our recent trip to Italy oh let
me see I'm going to my sign actually
it's a beautiful picture of the Italian
countryside of course it looks pretty
damn home what yeah no that was just a
well-intentioned little poke in the ribs
between friends that's all exactly I'm
glad you realize grace this one is for
ya come here by the way anybody join me
on the couch if you like now join you in
a second and no my nipples would be like
jello what does this picture make you
think oh my god I think uh TZ Vince I
really wet what a day day no I just want
one word one word one word oh sorry one
word have to be so okay it will have to
be pubic hair it's a two word I got damn
it oh man all right there's romance
hellos enough yeah all right whoa
spinnings romance all right I took this
picture on my own Preda suede race was
too tired to leave the hotel room frayed
can weeds jet-lagged up talking about
that thank you
why use our shock disguisting boarding
you even have to be so communicative I
do have a problem with my communication
huh Oh
here you're quite the kidder tonight
that was not a joke ha ha ha yeah
what's up buddy it's not a job anything
that pops into your mind
what that's pop I don't even need does
all right here we go it's time for the
ultimate test
come here it's time for Zala that we
didn't come here to hear this what
you're gay you're coming out of the
closet trip it's okay if we just it's
okay trip you can do it come out I was a
class very trip is well you have to
appreciate how after a full day's work
designing magazines guys can one copy at
a time
shut okay keep your cool we're finishing
this we're finishing this don't I know
what's that annoying sigh thing you got
there trip yeah what you happy I knew
you'd like it
see grace yeah I do like how good all
this looks and and I'm so [ __ ] up I'm
sorry
what's that annoyed sigh about my
decorating I know at work I waste all
day designing ads for apartments like
this and it makes me think I want this
style for my apartment this style makes
me feel like I'm inside one of your ads
it's great your ad fit oh there's
something else coming together at all
not coming together like your [ __ ] and
trips penis I'm sorry I can't say it
goddamn it
I want to say it it's not alright stop
saying that
oh that's just a little joke
advice-giver toy let's give it a try
you know trip that little advice ball of
yours doesn't look good on the bar what
is hilarious raise our kids
hey cream it's a crush plastic sitting
let's see this it's definite well done
great well done actually check them
besides I like the part I didn't need
this plaid all right trip your turn ha
ha Gonzalo is your prospect harsh or not
I'd say that right why that face maybe
later
oh I get at you two or maybe someone
else since chip is coming at it's
definite what oh I guess she's he's
watching handsome gorgeous what we
really have to do um dance can we dance
we've got any way to do that look at ya
yeah floor yeah the floor cleaner thingy
what are you talking about
what's going on here right do you want
me to lead you remember to return that
yeah oh I can't believe you just said
that trip grace what everything's we
need drinks definite I know I'm gonna
open us a magnificent I mean astounding
Ordo what's the hell of difference very
rare very difficult to a heart rate just
shut up dad with a hole and open not a
wine perfect oh here we go
love this no no out it Gonzalo how about
something simple like a nice glass of
chardonnay whatever has no need to open
this girl her friend is here we're gonna
enjoy ourselves that's all there is to
it
see I've been dying to try this Bordeaux
for a long time this is the best
opportunity
oh god damn it so much top Bordeaux we
saved from our wedding
is this the bottle ah open a wedding and
ah right why are you yelling [ __ ] why
ah you're driving me insane
Shh everyone goddamn anniversary one
everyone just Shh
what what what are you saying to me what
I'm saying Shh okay yeah I hear you all
right now you're not supposed to hear
anything it's just Shh
everyone gonzalo take a moment and let
ya think
Gonzalo yeah I can guess what you're
about to say oh you goddamn
over-analytical expedited eyes anything
what's your freakin problem huh acting
so vulgar
he has this brochure I was massaging on
tickets what's your problem
what why really rude where did that come
from
that was a combat man goddamn
manipulation grass Babbitt just wanna
get better better when I see that can't
we just do that do what each other all
right you know what
Gonzalo yes I need to ask you something
try grace
let me ask our guest to question I think
we're getting close
come on hallo yes or no uh side that was
not read can you try to change the other
person to be even better after you
yourself are what what is it okay to try
to quote on Paul are you tires mouse I'm
glad you're on improve yourself yes boss
then yes I think look don't bother
answer my ad let's hear it Oh priest yes
it doesn't kind of shallow person
obsessed with money that I don't love
you
you think our marriage is all just a
sham what's a sham I don't even know
that look you hate him run away my sight
can I kiss here but I don't want to look
at you but I won't
all right let's give her some comfort no
wait please
yes there we go much what do you guys
are you are you sorry this is a disaster
show them titties Gonzalo from what you
said before about helping your spouse
since that shows us something about trip
oh so we're talking about me are we
yes your um look at this point
criticizing me is just going to make
your regular body zombie a sad look
let's talk about us both not just one of
us admit that you're you see it's the
way you speak the way you yes Tim the
way you move I'm not allowed to be angry
you tell me what to do you dad it's so
annoying so hello right I'm not telling
if I'd never finish it can I do ah don't
whoa what the hell you scare me holy
[ __ ] don't look at me like that she's
seriously psycho I should just back okay
no I want to focus on grace fine you
know Tripp whenever I really try to talk
honestly about things you you don't want
to hear it
what Gonzalo is the only one who is
trying to be the most honest here I
doubt it but it's okay Oh Tom grace
grace give me a kiss and we'll see
look quit the flirting already ha ha ha
ha
what I'm not going to put what let's
continue focusing hey what's wrong with
a little flashy it's weird to me when
when I'm on a business trip Christ never
calls me ever ah
she says she's afraid to call me why
why yes oh you want to know more see
that might help him tell me what I mean
why is it something I'm let's I'll just
get naked no I don't want to get thrown
out I'm sorry it's all just he did
focusing on trunky ever now worst is
when problems on a business trip yeah
grace avoids me for days
Gonzalez that's gay no I mean no I don't
get it oh you don't get what yeah some
advice here get no yeah let's let's
focus on sex sex
that's why is sex such a big deal what
why I always talk about yes but not so
glad I'm just saying sex seems like it's
more trouble than it's worth she um this
is so depressing starting to think she's
a lesbo no you don't think so
like she doesn't want to have oh no dog
cry ah da na na na don't cry
I know it's tough when your girlfriend
is a lesbo exciton really knows it's not
an easy trick I'm so sorry
more about grace but your hova your
fault ten years ago freshly married and
just at all right we always been against
me go into advertising instead of art
and your heart through you huh
thought I got me like that Gonzalo you
saying I'm to blame
what yeah why did I marry you yes yes ah
thank you saying that might just help
him know he just met Sam Soon weightless
what are you possibly expected just cash
back you know what Gonzalo
that's it you need to leave I flipped
the table if I could i [ __ ] this guy up
you'll be fine
you just have to go I don't even want
and I'm going out of here take the
elevator and just screw that couple
tubes smithereens I'm never playing this
again I thought I will try to finish
this series with like a what I actually
finished game but I can't to do it it is
literally impossible so I don't know if
you finished game leave a video response
and people want to watch that they can
do that it's nothing more to it anyway I
had a really fun I would be serious I
think I might actually make a montage of
it cuz I don't know you both seem to
like it sir but every beginning must
have an end and I don't know I feel like
I kind of played enough of this game I
might throw more in the livestream or
whatever I'm not saying I'll never touch
this game but I probably never make a
video with any but yeah and that's I
guess we I call it an avenue of a series
so thank y'all for watching stay awesome
brush and find a new crazy game to play
for you that's pretty much it once it
taste marrow Oh
Danny it's a bright night
and I put it right I chopped
oh no no no all right here we go here we
go somewhere Oh